welcome all to our final event of the
semester end of the year my name is Dr
Ty Kemp and I'm assistant director of
the Frankie program in science and the
humanities
we're delighted that this year we've
started gathering in person once again
for our signature public talks and
convivial receptions I think for which
we are known
it's through the magnanimity of our
benefactors Mr and Mrs Richard Frankie
and Barbara Frankie that we have
produced such robust programming talks
ranging from such diverse topics as
overfishing on the Mexican Peninsula to
the Salvatore Mundi the Leonardo da
Vinci's lost painting we learned about a
few months ago to the history of CGI in
movies to novel interdisciplinary
approaches to architecture and the built
environment
we hope you've enjoyed this year of
talks and intellectual exchange at the
boundaries ever permeable between the
sciences and the humanities
before I introduce today's talk by Dr
Michael Kaplan I'm required to give this
rather officious notice Yale University
is photographing and videotaping this
event there's a possibility you may be
included in these visuals so by being
present during these activities you
consent to the use of your appearance
likeness and Voice by Yale University
for standard non-profit educational news
related Promotional and or editorial
purposes
it's rather legalistic but our
videographer is a lawyer so thank you
guy
could you tell
um also as per usual we shall be
gathering for our dinner reception
upstairs in fellows Hall tonight not the
student lounge but uh Frederick young
Frederick will Shepherd you there after
the event so please do stay for dinner
Our Guest today is Professor Michael
Kaplan the cnh long professor of
cellular and molecular physiology and
professor of cellbiology at Yale School
of Medicine where he's also the chair of
cellular and molecular physiology
Michael received his bachelor's degree
from Harvard in 1980 and his MD and PhD
degrees from Yale in 1987. so we can
praise him on that proper academic
trajectory going from Harvard to Yale
sorry I couldn't help
he joined Yale's Department of cellular
molecular physiology as a faculty member
in 1988 and has received fellowships
from the Helen hay Whitney Foundation
the David and Lucille Packard foundation
for science and engineering and a
national young investigator award from
the National Science Foundation
he has also received the young
investigator awards from the American
physiological society and the American
Society of nephrologists
Michael's work focuses on understanding
the ways in which kidney cells organize
and maintain their unique structures his
laboratory also studies the mechanisms
responsible for autosomal dominant
polycystic kidney disease and they are
working to identify targets for new
therapies really groundbreaking and
applicable work of import for us all
so his biography it's all his cerebral
as it is laudatory but I can tell you
from personal experience having worked
in his lab many years ago that Michael
is every bit as generous and supportive
of a mentor and professor as he is
accomplished and absolutely brilliant
the evidence of which you will soon
discover
he's also very very funny so I hope
he'll share some of his brand of humor
with us
as this is our final Gathering until
September uh when by the way we shall be
hosting a screening of my octopus
teacher maybe you've heard of this from
Netflix uh we'll be bringing in the
filmmaker for that so put it on your
calendar September 14th
um
I just want to take a little bit of time
to recognize ever some very important
colleagues of ours some of whom are here
Tony sudall whose technical expertise
makes our events possible
uh Rick Leone and his colleagues at Yale
broadcast especially our videographer
today uh guy ordoleiva who they record
our events and they turn them into
wonderful videos that receive many many
views on Yale's YouTube channel and our
website Matthew Jacob and the staff at
core Mandel Indian Cuisine who cater our
receptions David cerasi and his family
at Fitzgerald's florist in West Haven
because they ensure that our program has
arguably the best floral arrangements of
all Yale events and that's that's pretty
that's pretty high standard and also my
colleagues at the Whitney Humanities
Center who lend us tremendous support
each and every event and throughout the
year
um Matthew Hagan in particular Nessa
lascova Sandra Mellon Bulls Diane Brown
they do uh wonderful work and they do
their jobs enviously well and finally
Tanisha Leal and Jamar the custodial
staff for their wonderful support and
professionalism for all our events so
without further Ado Michael would you
please uh come up for your talk and
please join me in welcoming him
[Applause]
so thank you all for coming and thanks
especially to Tai for the invitation and
the opportunity to talk to you today
I am going to try to convince you that
the old expression art imitates life can
be read in both directions and that life
imitates art also and that some of
what's going on inside of us and inside
of ourselves is extraordinarily
aesthetically pleasing and can teach us
by looking at it as an aesthetic object
it can teach us something not only about
how it works but also why it's there
but I want to begin with a little bit of
an introduction to the discipline we're
going to be talking about and its
history
so the question is what is physiology
the these are two of my favorite
illustrations to try and address that
question
the picture on the right which we're
going to talk about a little bit more is
from the first systematic study of
anatomy by visalius it was drawn in the
1600s and I love the idea of a skeleton
contemplating itself
and to the left there's a picture by the
wonderful graphic artist Ben Sean which
is referred to as the scientist and
again
for me that the integration of the the
image of the scientist with the work
that the scientist is doing is
especially pleasing
so physiology is arguably the oldest of
the biomedical Sciences depending on
where you want to start counting
it could argue arguably
be credited back to Hippocrates about
2400 years ago and it could be credibly
said that Hippocrates was the first uh
physiologist
subsequently Galen uh about in the
second century CE
was the first person to really develop
theories about the circulation of the
blood in the body and he was had the
opportunity to develop his theories by
watching what happened to some of the
less successful of the Roman gladiators
and that allowed him to to learn a
little bit about what happened when
blood was allowed to leave its its
normal vessels
uh in the 1500s again we have visalius
whose name actually means the weasel
that was uh the family coat of arms and
actually if you visit the Yale School of
medicine's Historical Library his coat
of arms is on the far wall wall and it's
three weasels chasing each other don't
ask me why I don't know if he gave
himself that name or if he owed some
debts and it was given to him by his
creditors
um but visalius wrote the first
systematic book of anatomy called the
humani corporis Fabrica Libre septum
this is a picture of a dissection going
on in visalius's uh laboratory which was
in Bologna in Italy you can still visit
it today and it's an extraordinary
Anatomy theater fortunately it no longer
smells as it probably did at the time
that this sketch was made
uh and you can see visalius right here
who's leading the dissection so visalius
was really the first person who tried to
understand anatomy and related to
physiology and how things work and this
is the frontist piece from uh that first
Anatomy to corporate humanis and there
is actually an original copy of this
book which is entirely Priceless in
Yale's medical Historical Library so I
encourage you to go to the library I
encourage you to ask to see it and I
encourage you to not be disappointed
when they say no
uh William Harvey's book on the
circulation of the blood from the early
1600s Harvey was at Oxford and he was
the first person who really began to
figure out the relationship between the
heart the lungs and the pulmonary and
the systemic circulations although it
can be said that Arab Scholars including
IBN al-nafis proposed similar ideas much
earlier in the 13th century
Luigi galmani who also worked in bologna
and whose laboratory you can also visit
around the time of the Enlightenment in
the mid-1700s he and his wife working
together discovered that electrical
signals prompt muscle contraction and it
was really he and his work or he and his
wife and their work that gave rise to
the concept of bioelectricity and the
field of electrophysiology which is one
of the most prominent fields in
biomedical science today and it's
interesting to think about what was the
physiologic system that galvani chose to
study and those of you who are looking
carefully can see his experimental
preparation down here it is half a frog
so galvani used the bottom halves of
frogs and back in the day of Benjamin
Franklin instead of flying a kite he
attracted electricity and hooked it up
to a frog you can see two different
frogs hooked up to lightning rods here
and he saw that atmospheric attic
electricity was able to cause Twitchy
movements in the frog legs giving rise
to the idea that electricity was somehow
important in how our muscles contracted
and ultimately in how nerves conducted
and it wasn't really until the 1950s the
work of Hodgkin Huxley and cats in
England that led us to understand how
electricity is coupled to the action of
nerves and muscles
more recently William Beaumont can be
seen as the first American to pursue
studies of physiology and in fact if you
visit Yale medical school when you're
done looking at uh at the visalius
family crest if you go up a flight of
stairs there's a large conference room
at the medical school called The
Beaumont room with a portrait of
Beaumont in it Beaumont actually as far
as anyone knows never set foot at Yale
but he was highly admired and so there's
a whole room and a whole portrait of him
beaumont's claim to fame was that he was
in the right place at the right time and
a guy named Alexis Saint Martin was in
the wrong place at the wrong time so
Saint Martin was a soldier in the
Canadian military who caught a piece of
shrapnel in the abdomen
he survived and when the wound healed it
created what's called a fistula that
connected his stomach to the outside
world
so this poor guy was walking around and
was able to actually live a normal
reasonably healthy life but gastric
juice was was dripping out of this
fistula Beaumont had the wisdom to
recognize that maybe by collecting it
and measuring it it could tell us
something about what controls the
secretion of material into the stomach
and in fact Beaumont did the first
experiments on the relationship between
uh the the brain and acid secretion in
the stomach before Pavlov did his famous
experiments with his dog
so here's a picture of Beaumont draining
uh I don't know hopefully you can well
let me try this
so there's a picture of Beaumont
draining gastric acid from an
unfortunate but very patient Alexis
Saint Martin and I should say that
there's a large color painting of
Beaumont in the Beaumont room and a
small sketch of Alexis Saint Martin even
though in point of fact he and his
courage probably deserve the Lion's
Share of the credit
more recently and more relevant to this
talk are the two people who are seen as
the founders of modern physiology
so Claude Bernard was a French scientist
who coined the term milia interior
and by that he meant that we as
organisms who live in an air environment
are yet made up of 60 percent water so
we carry within us a volume of fluid uh
that is critically important for how
every cell in our body works and he
recognized that a large fraction of what
our bodies do is work to persist the
composition to maintain the composition
of that fluid because maintaining the
composition of that fluid is critically
important to all of the other
physiologic processes that get carried
out in the body so his idea was that the
maintenance of the milia interior the
interior milia is the main function of
all of our physiologic systems
Walter Cannon who was a scientist in the
first part of the 20th century at
Harvard
coined the term homeostasis to mean the
same thing in other words we have a
whole series of processes in our body
that exist to maintain a steady state to
maintain the composition of the Interior
Amelia and to ensure that it remains
compatible with all the lives of
ourselves
so what are the challenges that a cell
faces for a single cell organism like a
paramecium or an amoeba
the cell biological and physiologic
processes are one in the same in other
words anything that the cell needs to do
to stay alive is its physiology
and they're focused on the same goal
that is maintaining an organized
internal environment that's distinct
from the inhospitable outside world if
you're a paramecium swimming in a pond
your main job is to remain distinct from
the pond right you don't want to
dissolve and end up
distributed throughout the pond
so in essence the major task for a
single-celled organism and here I'm
going to tread between science and
philosophy and theology but the major
job of a single cell organism can be
summed up as harvesting and using the
energy that it needs to maintain the
subcellular structures that it has that
Harvest and expend energy in other words
a paramecium exists because it can
I don't in any way want to discount for
those of you whom it's important for the
role of divine intervention in this
whole process but the point is something
like a paramecium exists because a
paramecium can exist it has the
structures that it needs to harvest
energy whether it's from sunlight or
other sources
and use that energy to maintain its
composition to fight off the urge to
burst and and fuse with the pond
so
the the challenge for a paramecium is
how to use energy to solve that problem
so for a sing on the scale of a single
cell organism diffusion is fast enough
to ensure that small molecules the
nutrients that this paramecium is going
to eat for example can be absorbed
across the cell surface and readily
distributed throughout the whole cell
and we call the the makeup of the inside
of a cell the cytoplasm so the cytoplasm
can receive nutrients directly across
the cell's surface and that can feed all
of the aspects of the cell that it needs
to feed
we have exactly the same problem but on
a hundred thousand times or more larger
scale
so we have to harvest the energy that we
need to maintain all of our systems
again our main problem is to overcome
entropy to overcome the
inevitable forces that would otherwise
lead to our dissolution and Decay for
those of us for those of you who are
interested in Graves of famous
scientists not far from where we are in
the Grove Street Cemetery
uh is the grave of a guy named J Willard
Gibbs who was wanting one of the
founding faculty members of The
Sheffield School which subsequently
fused with Yale and became essentially
the colonel of its science departments
Gibbs was sort of the the founder of
modern thermodynamics and developed an
equation uh coincidentally named the
Gibbs equation
that explains the relationship between
energy and entropy and for those who are
are truly devoted to this and who are
interested in doing a very interesting
grave rubbing that equation is on his
headstone in the Grove Street Cemetery
at any rate we need to invest energy to
overcome the forces of entropy and to
maintain our composition and our
structure
but because we are far too big for
diffusion to be sufficient to carry all
of the things we need around our bodies
we have very complicated circulatory
system and distributed organ functions
that make all of that possible so
whereas the paramecium can get by having
everything in one cell in one place and
surviving by diffusion alone we have
distributed functions in the form of
organs each of those organs connected to
each other by a circulatory system
uh and each of those organs subserving a
specified individual function or series
of individual functions that were we
paramecium would be subserved by a
subcellular structure
for both single cell organisms and for
complex multicellular organisms like us
maintaining compositional Integrity
involves controlling the movement and
small molecules into and out of cells
obviously if you're a paramecium
floating around in a pond it's important
that water doesn't flow in swell you up
and cause you to explode but it's
important also that you can import
whatever nutrients you want from that
pond so that you can eat and you can
export whatever waste products you
generate
in the case of us we are composed of
cells trillions of cells and each of
those cells confronts the same problem
as a paramecium each of those cells for
all intents and purposes lives in a pond
or a salt water bath that is what we
call our extracellular fluid compartment
so a 60 kilogram person is carrying
around about 36 liters of water and that
36 liters of water is about 0.9 percent
saline so about a tenth the
concentration of seawater
and that maintaining that composition is
critically important to maintaining cell
function and each cell has to be able to
exchange with that extracellular fluid
what it needs to live on and what it
needs to get rid of
in your bloodstream and in your
extracellular fluid compartment is
glucose that your cell needs to create
energy or amino acids that the cell
needs to make proteins the building
blocks of the cell structure are nucleic
acids that the cell needs to make the
DNA an RNA that it uses to store and
communicate information the cell is
taking all of that up from outside of it
from the extracellular fluid compartment
and again getting rid of any waste
products it might generate
so each of our cells for all intents and
purposes has exactly the same problem as
this part these paramecia parameciai and
they need to figure out how to exchange
components with an outside environment
but maintain their own individual
compositional integrity
so really the focus of this talk is
going to be
what are the cells that form the
interfaces between our bodies and the
outside world what problems do they need
to solve and what structures allow them
to solve these problems so I'm going to
introduce you now to my favorite cell
type
and these are epithelial cells
epithelial cells are the cells that form
the barrier between the inside of you
and the outside of you and of course
when I say the barrier between the
inside of you and the outside of you the
first thing you think of is your skin
and that's a good guess the skin is an
epithelium but we have many more
epithelia as well so if you think about
it
the Lumen of your gut the inside of your
intestine is really continuous with the
outside world if you were flexible
enough and did enough yoga you could
turn yourself out inside out around your
gut and still be topologically
equivalent in other words the inside of
your gut is continuous with the outside
world and the cells that line your gut
have to form a barrier between the
inside of you and the outside of you
similarly the cells in your Airway your
trachea your lungs confront the outside
world
somewhat more subtly the cells in your
kidney do exactly the same thing
so there are all different variety of
epithelial cells in your body that are
forming all of these different and
interesting interfaces and their
structure beautifully reflects their
function both in forming the interface
and not being simply a stupid
impermeable barrier
but being an interface that is able to
communicate with its environment import
what it needs and Export what it needs
to get rid of
so epithelial cells are the barriers
between the internal and external
compartments they control the
composition and body of the volume of
body fluid compartments
and they are critically important to how
we maintain our homeostasis
I told you that you are composed of
about 36 liters of fluid
your kidneys are filtering all of that
fluid five times a day so whether you
know it or not you are making 180 liters
of filtrate in your kidney now I don't
know any of you very well except for my
wife and parents who are sitting here
but I'm going to guess that you produce
about two liters of urine a day
that means that your kidney has to
reabsorb 99 of what it filters it's the
epithelial cells that do that it's the
epithelial cells that are transporting
all of that salt and water
and their structure is critically
connected to how they're able to do that
as we'll see
so what do epithelial cells look like
what do they do and what are the
morphological or structural and
functional specializations that let them
perform their roles
so let's start with what epithelial
cells look like they come in lots of
different shapes and sizes
in cell biology we Define epithelial
cells as squamous that means flat
pancake-like and then there are cuboidal
and columnar epithelial cells and then
what we call pseudostratified and I'll
show you examples of all of them
what we're looking at here is frog skin
viewed from the top and hopefully you
share with me oh sorry you don't see
that hopefully you share with me an
appreciation for just how Exquisite this
pattern is
you see these pigment granules in some
of the cells and you see that these
cells form a Tessellation a tiling a
hexagonal array
of cells that fit together and form a
beautiful boundary that separates the
the frog from its pond
and these images actually inspired me to
to hang a piece of artwork on my wall
that's by Paul clay called ad Parnassus
and this is the same image that was used
in the the flyer that tie beautifully
prepared for this talk
this is an image by Paul clay that for
me reminds me very much of the structure
of an epithelial cell individual cells
linked together in a tiling in a
Tessellation and each one with its own
individual color structure
contributing to a whole
and again connecting art to life
Parnassus in Greek myth is the mountain
where the muses live and the origin of
Art and poetry so for me I love the idea
that that Parnassus at least in this
image connects up to an epithelium which
is my favorite kind of tissue
so I told you that the skin is an
epithelium this is a section of human
skin
this is the outside this is called the
stratum corneum and this is what faces
the outside world this is the stuff that
that
um
that is forming the the thickest part of
the barrier that prevents the outside
world from penetrating into you it's
also the part that flakes off from time
to time because this stratum corneum is
formed when the cells lower down in the
epidermis mature flatten out and die
so here's the epidermis these are the
cells that are going to give rise to the
outer layer of the skin and these cells
undergo an amazing process of
differentiation in other words
of acquiring a specialized appearance to
fulfill their function they start out
and hopefully you can see this as
cuboidal cells and as they migrate up
towards the surface they flatten out
into these pancake-like squamous cells
and then become these dead this dead
layer of impermeable material that acts
more or less like a wetsuit to keep the
outside world away from us and the
inside world away from the outside
it's beautiful work on the
differentiation of skin cells being done
here at Yale by Valentina greca at the
medical school for example
so we talked a little bit about what
epithelial cells can look like I showed
you skin and I also told you that they
can adopt many different shapes and
sizes that reflect their adaptation to
physiologic roles
so this is these are epithelial cells
from the gallbladder what I hope you can
see is that opposed to those skin cells
these are these guys are really tall
and they also form this hexagonal array
what you're looking at here is what's
called scanning electron microscopy it's
a specialized form of electron
microscopy that allows us to reconstruct
cellular shapes in three dimensions
what I love about this picture what I
find really striking is if any of you
who've had the Good Fortune
to travel to Scotland or Ireland and
seen the basaltic columns the volcanic
Columns of the Giant's Causeway or
fingles cave
you can see the resemblance between
these microscopic cells and these
macroscopic enormous structures that are
formed as lava cools
and the shapes
develop for essentially the same reason
which is that hexagons are a great way
to minimize the energy of things that
need to fit together coming back again
to Gibbs who's buried a few blocks from
here
I find this as a beautiful example of of
natural objects assuming similar
structures at hugely different scales
and and again seeing the the connections
in these shapes and the shapes that
we've adopted imitating these very
natural forms to carry out these
physiologic functions
these are cells of the intestine they
absorb nutrients and we'll talk more
about these kinds of cells in a little
bit you can see that these are very tall
columnar cells and they have this pink
little fuzz on them and I'm going to
show you in a minute what that fuzz is
made of it's actually hundreds of
individual hairs on each cell called
microvilli that increase the surface
area of these cells and increase their
ability to absorb things
because your intestine is there to
absorb what you eat and the more surface
area you have the more you can absorb
and these microvilli help increase that
surface area
these are cells of the airway
you can see that they have a different
kind of hair on their surface these
hairs are called cilia
you notice that some of the cells look
different
there are these cells called goblet
cells or mucous cells that have this
clear goop in the middle of them and
they secrete mucus they're secreting
mucus into your Airway and you may
Wonder especially at allergy season why
do we have mucus in our Airway that
seems aesthetically unpleasing
and the reason is that because we are
constantly breathing in stuff that we
don't want in our body dust bacteria
viruses if you have a nose like mine
small birds and we need to keep that
out of our Airways the mucus that these
cells secrete lines our Airways and
catches that stuff like fly paper
what I'm going to show you in a little
bit is that the Cilia on top of these
cells are actually
beating like little oars
and by beating they're moving that mucus
up towards our mouth and nose so that we
can cough or sneeze it out it's called
the ciliary escalator
so these motile cilia are critically
important to helping us keep pathogens
from entering our bodies and helping us
to get rid of them again specialized
adaptations that allow us to live in a
hostile world so these cells are called
columnar epithelia these are
pseudostratified
pseudostratified because these blue
blobs the nuclei don't line up in these
cells the way they do here
it looks like you have multiple layers
of cells but in fact it's one layer that
just is not as well vertically organized
so what are epithelial cells do and how
do they do it so I need to introduce you
now to some cell biology
this is a diagram of a more or less
typical cell and the first thing I want
to explain to you is that just as our
body is surrounded by a layer of skin
cells have a skin
but that skin is something called a
plasma membrane or a cell membrane and
that membrane forms the boundary between
the inside of the cell and the outside
of the cell so it's shown here in pink
uh
and this pink membrane is both going to
maintain the compositional Integrity of
the cell and determine what gets into it
and what gets expelled from it
you can also see that there are lots of
other goodies inside of this cell lots
of other subcellular structures that
we're going to talk about in Greater
detail
there's a nucleus and most of you are
probably familiar with the idea that the
nucleus of the cell is where the DNA is
stored and DNA carries the instruction
manual that the cell uses both to
reproduce itself and also to encode the
production of every one of the cell's
components the nucleus is where the
instruction manual from this from the
cell for the cell is stored and where
it's opened and read
the cell also contains mitochondria
mitochondria are energy generating
structures this is where the oxygen that
we breathe is used to help burn glucose
to make energy
so essentially our body derives all of
its energy from combustion it's a
controlled enzymatic combustion of
glucose turning that into carbon dioxide
and using oxygen to help us do that and
that happens in this structure called
the mitochondria which we're going to
talk about much more
I want to go a little bit deeper into
the structure of a membrane before we go
on
these membranes have to serve a couple
of different purposes again they need to
separate the inside of the cell from the
outside of the cell so it makes sense
that you'd want them to be impermeable
to water you don't want water to be able
to leak through
but on the other hand they have to be
able to let important things in and
important things out we need to let
glucose into the cell for example we
need to expel the acid byproducts of
metabolism out of the cell
so the cell membrane has to be both
water impermeable
but selectively permeable to things that
dissolve well in water
that seems sort of paradoxical how do
you do that
so the cell solves this problem with
something called a phospholipid bilayer
membrane lipids are a kind of fat
and lipids are of course water insoluble
all of us have had the experience of
working with salad dressing and you know
that the olive oil is floating on top of
the balsamic vinegar and not interacting
closely with it
membrane is made of very similar stuff
we know that it's made up of two layers
of phospholipid because of an experiment
that was done about a hundred years ago
by two people in Holland named Gorder
and Grendel
what they did was extract all of the
lipids from red blood cells
and they spread that out on the surface
of a water trough
and then they measured the surface area
of how much lipid was there
and then compared that to the surface
area of the red blood cells that they
had extracted it from and they realized
that there was exactly twice as much
surface area as there was surface area
on the red blood cell and that meant it
had to be a bilayer now in point of fact
they miscounted their red cells and they
miscalculated the surface area but they
were compensating errors so they came up
with the right answer for the wrong
reasons
I will say that this structure is
critically important to how I ended up
making a career choice
because when I was in college I took a
Cell Biology class and the professor
reproduced the Gorda and Grendel
experiment with a little bit of an
exciting twist
he spread out he took a a trough full of
methanol and he lit it on fire
and then he stuck his finger in his ear
to take out some earwax and dipped it
into the trough and the idea is that the
earwax is going to spread out on the
surface of the liquid forming a layer in
the same way that Gorder and Grendel's
lipids did in their trough and it would
put out the fire because that lipid
would be impermeable to oxygen and that
would have been dramatic and exciting
enough if the professor had not caught
his sleeve on fire
the vision of a flaming professor in a
Cell Biology course was all I needed to
dedicate my career
he survived
I told you that these membranes have to
function not only to prevent water from
moving across them but also to
selectively let substances like glucose
or ions Etc move through them
and they do that because they have
embedded within them proteins
proteins are polymers they're made up of
amino acids and essentially the most
important complicated and interesting
structures in our bodies are all made up
of proteins proteins are the engines
that do everything in our body all of
the enzymes you hear about are proteins
all of the structures in cells are
composed of proteins that endow them
with both their structure and functional
capacities
proteins are embedded in membranes and
they can serve as selective tubes or
channels that let stuff diffuse into and
out of cells in fact they can be even
smarter than that they can use energy to
actively pump stuff into and out of
cells so cells can control their
internal environment by pumping out
stuff they want to get rid of or pumping
in stuff they need
and they do that with these proteins
that are embedded in the membrane
these proteins are linked to each other
and structural Integrity is provided to
the membrane by virtue of a skeleton
what's called a cytoskeleton that is
present beneath the surface of the
membrane and that acts as a meshwork
that attaches each of these proteins to
each other some of the seminal work on
this was done Years Ago by Vince
Marchese in the Pathology Department
here at Yale who characterized the
proteins and the interactions that
mediate the formation of the skeleton in
the red blood cell
so if we put these components together
what does a cell look like this is a
liver cell you can see it has a nucleus
it has some of the mitochondria we were
talking about and it's got other
structures like endoplasmic reticulum
Golgi lysosomes so let's look at some of
these in a little bit greater detail
we're now looking in what we call a
transmission electron microscope so
we've cut a very very thin section of a
cell
and we've magnified it many thousands of
times and what you're seeing here is the
nucleus of the cell the black stuff is
the DNA the white stuff is material in
between the DNA and this nucleus forms a
defined structure sitting in the in the
center of the cytoplasm
you can also see that there are these
smooth surface membranes
out here just next to the nucleus
and those are what are called the
endoplasmic reticulum one of my favorite
terms in cell biology because whenever
you say endoplasmic reticulum you sound
smart so it's just a good word to have
on hand
see these little dots that are sitting
on the endoplasmic reticulum these
little black blobs
these were discovered in the 1950s by
George Pallotti who I was fortunate
enough to have as one of my thesis
advisors
and they were identified as the site in
which the cell makes proteins
so DNA in the nucleus carries the
instructions for how we make everything
in the cell
basically it's the instructions for how
every protein in the cell is made
those instructions get copied down into
a a little notebook that gets exported
from the nucleus called messenger RNA or
ribonucleic acid and ribosomes sit on
that messenger RNA and read that code
and use that code to make proteins
that's what's called the central dogma
of biology the information in the DNA is
transcribed into RNA is read by
ribosomes to make proteins
now you see that some of these ribosomes
are sitting on top of the endoplasmic
reticulum and they're there to solve a
complicated problem
that I didn't mention earlier on but
that is associated with these proteins
being in a membrane how do you get a
protein stuck into a membrane and
organized in the right way
and the answer is that these ribosomes
can essentially act as a sewing machine
as the protein is being made and emerges
from the ribosome it's sown across the
membrane through a special tube or
tunnel that's present in the membrane of
the endoplasmic reticulum so that
proteins can be woven into the surface
of the membrane and endowed the cell's
membranes with the proteins that they're
going to need to carry out all of their
functions
and actually it was for figuring this
out that pilate along with Gunter Global
separately won the Nobel Prize in
physiology and Medicine
here's endoplasmic reticulum here's
another structure that was discovered by
Pilates again in the 1960s called the
Golgi complex
proteins that get made in the
endoplasmic reticulum get carried in
little cargo vesicles little uh
essentially packages that butt off the
endoplasmic reticulum travel through the
cytoplasm fuse with the Golgi and in the
Golgi those proteins undergo maturation
reactions to help them be prepared for
their next role so the Golgi complex is
the next step in the assembly line as
these proteins get made and travel
through the cell
these are pancreatic aciner cells these
are the cells that secrete all of the
digestive enzymes that your pancreas
makes
and your pancreas stores those enzymes
in these blobs called secretory vesicles
Jim Jameson who was then a student in
George Pilates lab wondered if he could
figure out how proteins travel
from the endoplasmic reticulum
how proteins travel from the endoplasmic
reticulum to the Golgi complex to the
Golgi complex to the cell surface
because at the time he was doing those
experiments in 1967 it was not known it
was known there was an endoplasmic
reticulum a Golgi secretory vesicles but
how did things travel
so Jameson did a really smart experiment
he took pancreatic acini and fed them
radioactive amino acids now any Protein
that's going to be made is radioactive
and at various times after feeding them
radioactivity
he cut sections of them
and coated them with a photographic
emulsion
the photographic Emulsion would get
would deposit silver grains wherever
there were radioactive particles
so basically by looking at where the
silver grains go he could figure out
where the newly synthesized proteins
were traveling
so hopefully you can see these black
blobs here
are silver grains over the endoplasmic
reticulum
and when he waited about 10 minutes or
so you could see that now the black
blobs are over the Golgi complex
and if he waited longer they were in
immature and then mature secretory
granules Jameson did that experiment as
a student in George Pilates lab he
actually did it while pilate was on
vacation because Pilates really didn't
want him to do this experiment he'd set
him on another project that was totally
impossible Jim wanted to do this
experiment Pilates said no Jim did it
well George was away on vacation and
this result was a big part of why George
won the Nobel Prize but Jim received a
lot of credit so it all worked out in
the end
okay so I've introduced you to
components of cells now let's see how
they come together in an epithelium like
the kidney
so
this structure here is a glomerulus I
told you that your kidney filters 180
liters of fluid a day you have about a
million of these glomerular structures
in each of your kidneys
the filtrate that's formed from this
glomerulus enters a tubule called the
nephron or the the tubule of the kidney
and these cells that line the earliest
part of the Nephron are we what we call
proximal tubule cells
the fluid flows through the nephron and
again about 178 liters of it is going to
get absorbed by an assembly line series
of processes that require different
steps at each stage
and you can see that these cells of the
proximal tubule look different than
cells of the distal tubule look
different than cells of the collecting
tubule each of the cell types that are
going to carry out a function are
specially adapted structurally and
functionally to do that
I want you to pay attention to the
striations in the base of this cell you
see how interestingly striated the
bottom of this cell is we're going to
talk about that more in a second
this is what these cells look like in a
transmission electron microscope these
are the proximal tubule cells I told you
about
you can see that they've got something
really interesting going on in the Lumen
of the tubule
you can also see that these cells are
full of mitochondria
huge numbers of mitochondria remember
mitochondria are where the cells
generate energy why does the kidney need
so much energy here in the proximal
tubule here in the distal tubule huge
numbers of mitochondria
the answer is that we are pumping 180
liters of salt water from the Lumen of
that kidney tubule back into your body
the pumps that do that burn a huge
amount of metabolic energy eight percent
of the oxygen consumption that your body
carries out is used by these
mitochondria and kidney cells to
transport all of that salt water back
into the body
let's look more closely at these
microvilli these structures on the
proximal tubule cells that are filling
the Lumen of this proximal tubule here
this is what they look like in a
transmission electron microscope you can
see they're about a micron long a micron
being a millionth of a meter or a
thousandth of a millimeter and there are
hundreds of them on the surface of the
cell
so this is them at low magnification
this is them at high magnification
here in scanning electron microscopy you
can see this beautiful brush-like
appearance and in fact this is called
the brush border
and if you cut cross sections of them
this is what each of these guys looks
like in the middle they're scaffoldings
that run up the middle of it and one of
the people who's done the most to figure
out what that scaffold is made of is a
brilliant scientist here at Yale named
Mark mosiker who's in the department of
molecular cellular and developmental
biology and understanding that skeleton
has been key to understanding providing
us an understanding of how these cells
work
I'm showing you here two different modes
of electron microscopy
very excitingly there's now a third mode
of electron microscopy where there are
many modes of electron microscopy but
there's a new one that's just come to
Yale
called focused ion beam scanning
electron microscopy what we can do now
is take three-dimensional images through
a cell most of you know or have
experienced what a CAT scan is a CAT
scan computerized tomography allows an
x-ray machine to generate
three-dimensional cross-sectional images
through you
focused ion beam scanning electron
microscopy allows us to do the same
thing on a piece of tissue on the order
of the size of a human hair
and so what you're looking at here is a
portion of the inside of one of these
proximal tubule cells the orange guys
are the mitochondria the green guys the
endoplasmic reticulum the yellow is the
cell surface and now for the first time
we can appreciate in three dimensions
how all of these structures are
interacting with each other and talking
to each other and what you can see is
there are tremendous connections between
these structures and we're just starting
to understand how those connections form
and what those connections do
now if epithelial cells are going to
form a boundary between the inside of
you and the outside of you they have to
be connected to each other
if you put tiles down on a floor
those tiles need to be connected to each
other by some sort of grout or something
to keep the the outside surface from
getting underneath the tiles
cells have Junctions that hold them
together
they have things called tight junctions
that prevent the inside World from
leaking out and the outside world from
leaking in
and they also have things called
desmosomes that act as rivets or spot
welds that hold the cells together and
form the structural Integrity that
allows the epithelium to persist
so this is a cell biologist's view of
epithelial cells
this is a physiologist's view of
epithelial cells these are epithelial
cells that are transporting salt these
are epithelial cells of your kidney and
they're absorbing sodium chloride salt
water from outside of the body to inside
the body
and if you rearrange some of these same
Transporters now you have the cells in
the airway or in the gut that secrete
fluid to keep the mucus in the airway
fluid so I'm not going to go into any of
these details I just want to point out
that those same proteins that I told you
about that are embedded in the membrane
are serving roles as pumps as channels
as carriers that are moving things
across the membrane and where they are
in the cell determines the properties of
the cell
what are those Junctions I told you
about look like in the electron
microscope this is a modality called
Freeze fracture electron micro
microscopy where cells are frozen and
they're actually hit with a guillotine
blade that splits that bilayer membrane
into two they're then shadowed with
platinum and we can see the platinum in
the electron microscope and you can see
hopefully this beautiful lattice work
these latticework are the tight
junctions which are acting essentially
as a garden fence that prevents the
inside from diffusing into the outside
the outside diffusing into the inside
so this structure and the number of
lines in this latticework correlate
beautifully with how tight these
epithelia are the more lines we have the
higher the resistance to flow between
these two domains
here's one of those desmosomes the spot
welds that give structural strength to
the epithelium and you can see that it
looks just like a rivet so even though
it's at a tiny microscopic scale on the
order of
a fraction of a micron it looks just
like the kinds of rivets that you might
have in your Gene that's genes that hold
your pants together
I told you about the Cilia that are on
the surface of Airway epithelial cells
these motors that beat and that move the
mucus towards your mouth and nose the
same cilia move eggs through the oviduct
in advance of fertilization
so they're critical motile functions to
these cilia and this is what the Cilia
look like in the airway epithelium in a
light microscope here's what they look
like in cross section
it's an Exquisite structure where you
can see nine uh
nine rows of what are called
microtubules that are connected to each
other by this latticework and to a
central pair of microtubules and there
are Motors that move those microtubules
that slide against one another
and that cause these cilia to beat
a lot of this was figured out actually
here at Yale by Joel Rosenbaum who did
ground bake breaking work on clammy
demonis which is actually a motile algae
and has a tail that allows it to swim
what Rosenbaum figured out using clammy
demonis turns out to be critically
important to human disease because there
are people walking around with diseases
called ciliary dyskinesia or cardenegger
syndrome where the Cilia don't move and
those people can have multiple Airway
infections they can have problems with
fertility all because of the motors that
move these cilia don't work and in fact
polycystic kidney disease the disease
that Ty mentioned that our lab studies
is also related to dysfunctions of the
Cilia
finally coming back to the kidney I want
you to notice
that this kidney cell
has a huge mitochondria filling almost
its whole cytoplasm again remember these
guys need to use lots and lots of energy
to pump salt and water
and you can see that the membrane of the
cell
is folded around these mitochondria the
membrane of these kidney cells
are ruffled just like or or a pleated
just like if you open a curtain if you
open a drape you get pleats in that
drape that increases the surface area of
this cell membrane
so this cell has all of these folds in
order to increase its surface area so
that it can carry more pumping apparatus
so that it can move that salt and water
and look there are mitochondria sitting
right next to those pumps prepared to
deliver energy to the pumps we still
don't know how the mitochondria know to
go there one of the things I'm excited
about working on in my lab is trying to
understand who tells the mitochondria to
go to these pleats how does the cell
know where it needs its various
components
but another thing that's really exciting
about the work we do in the lab is just
how aesthetically beautiful it is these
are images of kidney tubules in green
we've stained for the mitochondria and
you can see uh the striated structures I
told you about before in these cross
sections of kidney tubules correspond to
where the mitochondria are here's a
different view of the same thing these
green circles cross sections of
mitochondria here cells grown in a
three-dimensional Matrix to form a cyst
and again you can see mitochondria
traveling through the whole length of
the cytoplasm
so for me
what I carry away from this is this
beautiful idea that the form of the cell
very much follows its function and we're
just beginning to understand how that
works we know that all the information
you need to make a cell is present in
the nucleus and we're still just
learning how it is that that information
is interpreted in each cell type to make
each of these unique structures
and looking at these in unique
structures is both a joy and a privilege
because they're so exquisitely beautiful
and bringing me back to the the theme
and title of the lecture our bodies the
cells of our bodies have a remarkable a
beautiful array of structures whose
distribution allows us to maintain our
interior milia and allow us to carry our
worlds with us so at this point I want
to thank you very much for your
attention and I'd be happy to answer any
questions you might have
it was wonderful I knew it would be
thank you Michael
Frederick has the microphone so we just
ask that you use that for your questions
so all the questions will be picked up
on the video feed if I may begin though
with the first one I've read and forgive
my ignorance that mitochondria are it
came to us through endosymbiosis right
so they were bacteria evolutionarily
speaking so could you talk then a bit
about about how maybe that that came to
be and what
um
what ways in which they might have
addressed uh they might have developed
solutions for for their processes is
that similar to the way epithelial cells
have or because they were uh bacteria is
it a totally different kind of solution
that they developed that's a fact that's
right so that's a great question and
there are a number of layers of answers
to that so what Tai is referring to is
that if you look carefully at those
mitochondria and if I were to show you
an electron micrograph of a bacteria
they would look sort of similar and in
fact at a molecular level they are kind
of similar in fact each mitochondria has
its own DNA each mitochondria has its
own genome that it carries with it that
encodes some but not all of the proteins
that it needs and that led to the
hypothesis which has since been
abundantly proven that mitochondria are
bacteria that somehow ended up being
absorbed into and maintained by our
cells so
we are what are called eukaryotes or our
cells are eukaryotic eukaryotic means
cells with nuclei
cells without nuclei are prokaryotes
somewhere early in the evolution of
eukaryotes there were some eukaryotic
cells sitting around a whole bunch of
prokaryotic cells and they somehow
endocytosed or absorbed those
prokaryotic cells
and it occurred to them that hey this
works pretty well because the
prokaryotic cells were able to harvest
chemical energy and produce it in ways
that the cells could use and the cells
could provide nutrients and needs that
the prokaryotes use many of you may know
that in coral reefs the coral polyps
have algae living symbiotically within
them
it's exactly the same thing the
mitochondria that live within us
were at one time free living bacteria
that have now evolved so close to being
a part of us that they couldn't live
without us and we couldn't live without
them
now those mitochondria need to address
somewhat different problems than our
whole cell they're not concerned with
maintaining the inside of them and the
outside of them because they live inside
a pouch inside a cell
but they are actually confronted with a
problem that directly relates to what
they're supposed to do they use oxygen
to help generate energy it turns out
that oxygen is really toxic
that doesn't make a lot of sense right
we need oxygen to breathe when we're
deprived of it we start to get really
anxious really fast
but it turns out that oxygen is very
chemically reactive
and one of the things mitochondria one
of the problems they need to solve is
how to prevent themselves from being
damaged by the oxygen that they're using
and I won't go into the biochemistry of
it but a lot of what mitochondria are
doing is both
perfecting the energy the mechanisms of
energy production and perfecting the
mechanisms of keeping themselves from
Deep being damaged by the oxygen that
they use these little folds inside the
mitochondria are called cristae and
within those Chris day are the molecular
machines that we use to generate energy
I won't go into the the mechanism now
but each of those
protein complexes functions exactly like
a water wheel
the principle by which our body
generates energy is exactly the same
principle that's used by water wheels if
you drive up to Vermont and are lucky
enough to still still see an older
recreated water wheel on an old Dam
there's a structure that spins and that
spinning is exploited in the same way a
hydroelectric Dam exploits a spinning
turbine to generate what's called ATP
which is the chemical form of energy
that our cells use
so at any level of resolution that you
look at it there are extraordinary
structures extraordinary machines and
the the engine that generates that ATP
is very very similar to the one that's
used in bacteria
hi uh what you're just speaking about
I'm not a scientist so I'm going to say
what you were just speaking about and
also there was a slide where you discuss
how some people have fertility problems
and where the um
a little bit like this SEC Center photo
it was yeah no Sky the circular one
where it's um this guy yeah it's very
orderly as far as which way these things
are going they are it's not random and
it kind of reminds me of a lecture of
that was about why is our heart on the
left side and like why everything else
is symmetrical and I don't remember the
reason why I might have had something to
do with gravity and when the embryo
develops or something but so I wondered
if you can speak a little that is a
beautiful question and actually uncovers
a very
subtle point so
you're absolutely right that we are
mostly bilaterally symmetric our left
hand sort of looks like a mirror image
of our right hand but there are organs
in our body that are distributed
non-uniformly our heart is on the left
side our liver is on the right side
uh spleen is on the left side how does
that happen
how do we break that bilateral symmetry
it turns out that in the earliest cells
of the embryo
these cilia beat and they beat in a
structure called Cooper's vesicles to
move fluid around in a precise Direction
it turns out that the movement of that
fluid in a precise Direction Only In One
Direction is absolutely required to
create our body asymmetry
and actually beautiful work is done on
that at Yale by Mustafa coca and by
Martina Bruckner who are understanding
the mechanisms by which the beating
that's created by these cilia creates a
movement of fluid in this tiny little
Fishbowl at the tip of the embryo that's
sensed by antenna literally that stick
up into it and the bending of those
antenna in response to the movement of
the fluid by these um
by the Cilia is required for our
asymmetry and people who have genetic
problems that
can't make their cilia move end up with
body parts on the wrong side
so you can end up actually with your
heart on the right and your liver on the
left as long as as it happens completely
you can live a perfectly normal life and
surprise your friends at parties by
saying Hey listen to my heart and they
don't hear it because it's on the other
side
so these ciliary dyskinesias can produce
complete breakdowns or or reversals of
bilateral symmetry uh so the Cilia are
critically important to not only moving
things through the airway and the
oviduct but also during embryonic
development so that was a very good
memory
of existence sort of because in that
lecture they were trying to figure out
why
what's inside of us it must have some
relation I mean that's like the center
of gravity like the gravity pull like it
has some relation to something that's
outside
why the heart is where it is if that
makes sense like there's some
interaction between
we are beings on an Earth with a gravity
pull like so I is there any
just think about that
yeah kinda so
um
when we're standing up
it's hard for the blood that's pumped by
our heart down to our legs to come back
up to the heart
so in fact uh
when we walk around the movement of our
muscles that squishing movement helps
squeeze blood out of the veins back
towards the heart if you sit for a long
time like in a lecture where someone is
talking for too long like I am
blood can pool in your feet and I don't
know if you've ever read the back of the
airplane magazines where it tells you on
a long flight you're supposed to move
your legs around so that the blood
doesn't pool in your legs and form a
clot
it is absolutely true that gravity
is a force that we need to contend with
in order to maintain our circulation
when you lie down it's much easier for
fluid to come back to the heart than
when you're standing up
some people who have trouble with their
hearts who have something called heart
failure will find that fluid can build
up in their legs during the day and when
they lie down that fluid moves out of
the legs and returns to the heart
and actually gets sent to the kidneys
and they find that they have to get up
in the middle of the night to urinate
many times a night because the fluid
that was in their legs is now being
delivered back to the heart is being
delivered to the kidneys which say hey
there's too much fluid here we need to
get rid of some so gravity plays a big
part in
the specializations that our body has
developed to move things around in a
world that that isn't completely
symmetrical if that makes sense
sure
hi good to see you
hi Mike have you talked about nephrotic
syndrome so I didn't so that's a very
interesting
uh topic that I didn't get time to talk
about remember I remember I said that
that we have a million of these
glomeruli in each of our kidneys
those glomeruli filter the blood and
produce 180 liters of filtrate now your
blood has salt water in it it has cells
in it and it has a lot of proteins in it
the kidney filtrate has the salt and the
water but none of the blood cells and
none of the proteins so you've got an
amazing filter in your kidney that can
filter out all of the protein and let
the salt water through
there's a condition called nephrotic
syndrome
where the ability of that glomerulus to
filter out the protein breaks down
and now the protein can end up
in the urine
now that wouldn't be such a big problem
by itself except we need that protein in
our blood because that protein helps
keep fluid in our capillaries
there's a complicated mechanism whereby
the presence of protein in the
capillaries is critically important to
determining the balance of fluid in our
capillaries versus in our tissues if we
lose the protein in our capillaries
fluid can flow out into our tissues and
produce huge swelling what's called
edema
patients with nephrotic syndrome
usually it's children will wake up one
morning and be completely swollen they
look like the stay puffed marshmallow
man because now they can't keep fluid in
their capillaries it flows out into
their tissues
fortunately it's usually self-limited
can be treated with steroids and it goes
away as mysteriously as it comes
but most of us have probably seen the
very horrifying pictures of children who
are starving a condition called
kwashiorkor
have you ever wondered why those
children have enormously big bellies
these kids are starving why are their
bellies so big
it turns out that they don't eat enough
amino acids to make proteins they don't
have enough proteins in their blood to
keep the fluid in their capillaries and
the fluid ends up pooling in their
abdomen
so it's the same mechanism as nephrotic
syndrome except in nephrotic syndrome
protein is being urinated out in protein
calorie malnutrition protein isn't being
made
but there's a a critical physiologic
Force called the Starling Force whereby
protein is necessary to keep fluid in
capillaries and that's lost in nephrotic
syndrome when when protein is lost in
the urine
so thank you for the question
mother
yes is the answer
[Laughter]
first of all I'm very proud of you thank
you
secondly I have always been since I was
a child very fascinated by Darwin and
how we evolved because we needed things
how can you take a structure like the
kidney or or even what you described
that so minute and apparently so
important and how does the body know
or how did The evolutionary workings
know that this little minute thing that
goes around in a circle is necessary to
do the next thing right so the question
is how could something so beautiful and
intricate arise from random
experimentation and right this is the
the question that motivates the debate
between intelligent design and
darwilliam darwinian evolution
and the answer is and there's very good
evidence for it that this happens by a
lot a lot a lot of random
experimentation random mutation over
time that produces huge numbers of
different changes most of which don't
work
but the ones that do work give each cell
or each organism a selective advantage
that allows it to use that structure to
do better and that structure can then
get improved by the next change or
mutation etc etc so in response to Ty's
question
I mentioned that
um
these mitochondria used to be bacteria
bacteria have a lifespan and that's
measured in you know hours to days right
so bacteria should not invest in in
long-term savings bonds or anything they
are turning over really really quickly
they're dividing incredibly quickly
they undergo huge numbers of mutations
random changes in their DNA most of
those mutations don't do these bacteria
any good and their bacteria offspring
are not going to succeed
but the ones that do succeed that build
a better way to harvest energy to make
chemical energy that cells can use
they're going to have a huge selective
advantage and they're going to to become
the most important bacteria in the slime
and so
those mechanisms have been have been
proven beautifully through what we call
directed Evolution there's a whole
science now that was started by a woman
named Francis Arnold who won the Nobel
Prize for this
who said well if evolution can work this
way maybe we can use it for our
advantage maybe we can convince bacteria
to do new things that they couldn't do
before like eat oil spills or chew up
plastic or make proteins that we need
for biomedical uses
so what she and her colleagues and the
people who have followed through on on
the principles that she developed have
done
is to just expose bacteria to chemicals
that would mutagenize them
and then come up with a way of selecting
for the bacteria that have the
properties they want and saying look I
don't care how you figure this out
bacteria but I want one of you to figure
out how to chew up oil
get back to me when you've done it uh
and so we can actually speed up
evolution by increasing the rate of
random mutagenesis and increasing the
rate of natural selection so not only
does it work not only is that the way
this happened but we can actually
engineer it and use it to our advantage
yeah everything nowadays is a little
scary
would you go back to the the Cilia sure
everyone's favorite side apparently
um
arcilia
throughout the body thusly organized
with the Ring of nine are all silly like
this and they're distinct from
microtubules right do microtubules and
cross-section look the same way and are
they or do they differ depending on
their location right so
here are microtubules in cross-section
and you can see that there are parallel
arrays of filaments that happen to be
made up of a protein called actin that
fills these filaments about a few dozen
of them per microtubule
microvilli can move but nowhere near as
well and nowhere near as coordinated as
cilia
cilia are made up of these arrays of
microtubules that are made up of a
protein called tubulin and connected by
radial spokes that hold those tubules
together
and Motors called dynine and kinesin
that use energy to make these motor
these tubules beat in a in a systematic
way
there are two kinds of cilia in your
body they're the movable cilia that we
call motile cilia that have nine rings
of tubules and a central pair and then
there are non-motile cilia what we call
uh
the the
um
well the non-motile Cilia which is
present in almost every cell in our body
it doesn't beat but it acts like an
antenna in fact in the kidney each cell
has a cilia that's sticking out into the
Lumen and as fluid flows past it it
bends like a reed in a stream
and screwing up the sensing of that
fluid flow is part of what leads to
polycystic kidney disease and beautiful
work on that has been done by Steve
somlow here at Yale among others but
sensory cilia or primary cilia
are involved in sensing chemicals
sensing physical stimuli so the the
cells in our eye that detect light the
light sensors are actually a specialized
psyllium in our nose the chemo sensors
that detect smells are a specialized
cilia so there are mechanical and
chemically sensitive cilia that look
just like this except they don't have
the central pair and don't move
but a subset of tissues in our body have
motile cilia like the airway like the
oviduct and those use cilia in in a
different way to create this fluid flow
to create this motion
like a little Misty foggy
unconnected but you had a slide
well it's this it's basically the
question about why is kidney disease
nephratitis or what is isn't that the
root is death where you know other
diseases you have appendicitis or
pancreatic type but you had to sell
facet it was purple that would had the
Neff I just wondered is there a relation
and the naming of things that that
kidney disease was actually equated with
like sure death or something whereas
yeah well so so prior to 1960 something
if you lost kidney function
you were going to die there was not a
lot that could be done for you in the
1960s renal dialysis was developed so
that people who had kidney failure the
functions of the kidney to get rid of
waste products and to maintain salt and
water balance could be maintained by
dialyzing the blood that is running it
through a machine and doing the same
cleaning process that the kidney
normally does and then subsequent to
that the development of transplantation
medicine allowed
the replacement of a ailing kidney with
the donor kidney if someone is fortunate
enough to get one
but the kidney is Far and Away not the
only organism organ whose dysfunction
can can lead to Serious disease or death
I mean obviously that's true of the
heart that's true of the brain it's also
true even of the pancreas if you lose
the ability to secrete insulin that
could limit your lifespan basically to
weeks and back in the days before the
discovery of insulin there was no way to
treat someone who had uh
type 1 diabetes in fact the first
discussion of the discovery of insulin
and its ability to reverse the symptoms
of type 1 diabetes was a lecture
delivered here at Yale 102 years ago by
Banting of Banting and Best the
discoverers from Toronto who discovered
insulin and presented it at Yale at a
meeting of the American physiological
Society so Yale played a minor role in
at least disseminating that Discovery if
not in the making of the discovery so
yeah I mean we have lots of body organs
and we need them
they each do different things just like
the different components of a cell are
required to keep that cell working and
healthy each of our organs are required
to keep the whole body working and
healthy
so so so the the Greek word for kidney
is nephros and the the structures the
tubules of the kidney are called
nephrons
so you have a million nephrons in each
of your kidney those nephrons are long
tubes of epithelial cells that carry out
all of this salt and water transport
sure
I think the the root maybe you were
thinking of is necro for death right
like necrosis like necrotic
right so that's a Greek Greek root for
for death
okay
um any other questions
okay well thank you please join me again
in thanking Michael
a wonderful talk
[Music]